we will commemorate such commemorative minutes stream
vast amounts of
memories repeating that i once
wrote
[music]
and quietly and
the others
experience the experienced structures flow
more
maybe
red
you plan
we owe you have
the chance to save life it's
like that i have to admit that i do
n't want to  say most but many of
a camera in the
concentration camp in their favor
because that saved them yuan
thought they ultimately tried
to come to life with the form at any price
what the
center absolutely
but i report given through  who
walked through these camp streets between
advisers here and there pulled the last piece of bread rusty
bag and called the
rescue before
or who had a good word an
encouraging encouraging word left
the camera close to the desperate
because I have the self-proclaimed  who
were not quite desperate
he just doesn't give in pessimism
he said so objectively
now there were hardly any
prospects
and another friend another
friend unknown one can in the camp he
was the one who got me up with a few
words with bathing
that's enough in such a  limit situation
understandable
unfortunately already deceased three years ago
an actor thank you
lagerbäck that's the essential
thing what a word can achieve what a
word can move is unbelievable with
such a situation that is connected
a word comes to decide or give up
or through in a war creation
signs of the political  his words
comes to decide as a
people in the relationship that has
been created by that it is a
human relationship that
expresses concentration just a
place at the right moment ending
supports
i remember that i was
in the camp in kaufering in bavaria so
that  one already after a  uschwitz came to bavaria from
exclusively that
i every day and we crammed into the snowy fields at six in the morning
the open shoes because the hunger
there was no more
room to close the school or no peak times bare feet open
school in the snow
stuttgart
again a ss  man cheered after the rifle butt
and promises to walk quickly
and is lagging behind will split
these snow-covered fields and someone
says there is not some tree or
despair
you can flow towards it and so that the ss
not only notices tributaries a word of
encouragement and coercion of the supervision
everything depends on the offer and worker the
word how you say it exactly right tenant
this word naturally hides a
condensed humanity
the viruses are sparks moving at once
but getting up and saying your gaze
to the sky helps
me
persevere
but not here then i felt  in the
net destiny
thank you stood